freiheit in deutschland das ist freiheit
auf deutschen autobahnen erkenntnis
grüne miesmacher können noch so sehr
motzen nirgendwo sonst auf der welt kann
man bei tempo 200 so entspannt 400
pferdchen galoppieren lassen guckt euch
doch an wenn ihr mit eurem porsche
fahren die meisten sind total verstrahlt
weißt du was das problem ist das für
euch ist das einfach nur eine
penisverlängerung nichts anderes das ist
nicht nur penisverlängerungen schimmel
oder bisschen schon aber aber passieren
da waren es elf fiel war so ich habe
doch nichts anderes was hat deutschland
sonst noch zu bieten außer autobahn
momente frei fahren kann eben und
deswegen ja deswegen deswegen das waren
sonst auch noch nehmen ja jetzt gibt es
ja tatsächlich bestrebungen um gute
kräfte im lande die sagen er ist ein
tempolimit er ja wenn ich hab's gut
dagegen warum
ja das ist die freiheit
[Musik]
wie wichtig ist es für sie dass man ein
großes auto fährt das ist das schwierige
frage also ich würde sagen das ist ein
auto in gewissen geschmack aus sagt
schenk darauf dass man geschmack hat
muss aber jetzt nichts neues sein oder
nichts großes nicht gefällt irgendwie
muss authentisch sein
naja du spürst gar nichts doch guck mal
holland ja fast 120 130 geht doch auch
halten und verwalten
doch die frische einer auf deutsch
gesagt hat tut sie doch wie die
schockierenden bilder einer typisch
holländischen autobahn beweisen sagte er
er geht weiter entschleunigung fanatiker
wie die grünen linke abgeordnete laura
brett haben jetzt in holland sogar tempo
100 durchgepeitscht will diese freiheit
feindin uns allen den letzten spaß
nehmen sie in holland hatten jetzt schon
ein tempolimit von 130 jetzt auf einmal
100 sei eigentlich total verrückt
geworden was soll das denn die natur
natürlich schutzgebiete und sind ihnen
schlechte kondition und sie leiten
unterrichtsstoff und langsam reite ich
langsamer fahren ist eine gute maßnahme
ich will jetzt eben als hingefahren bin
300 gefahren auf der autobahn
und jetzt muss ich hier auf der
holländischen autobahn 100
stundenkilometer fahren ich bin fix und
fertig wie schaffen sie das
dieses schöne deutsche sprichwort freie
fahrt für freie bürger gibt es das auch
auf holländisch freie fahrt für freie
bürger
ein bisschen tag schreiberin eine
freifahrt manche frauen wenn die panik
in panik wie plink coo auf seite und ist
doch nur 100 erlaubt ja aber es ist eben
genau das problem frauen und alte leute
weg von der autobahn und und nur die
kadima die die wirklich wissen wie es
klar ist was das beste ist ja noch das
ja alle ac jetzt auch noch auf einmal
neutrale sind ja dann steige ich dass
ich habe bloß da muss ich das ich habe
ihren vorschlag
das ist der adac der allgemeine freie
deutsche automaten autofahrerclub
übernachten hfg erzählte allgemeine
deutsche automobil-club ich will jetzt
auch mal gashebel wenig diskutiert ob du
die porsche fast oder parat jeder jeder
zweite pädagoge porsche finanzieren
lassen das haben wir gar nicht bitte
unter 20.000 euro kostet verbände eine
frechheit wir fahren jetzt ins stechen
auf auto hat man so auf meine freundin
was meinen sie ist dein auto lag dann
setzt sie sich mal rein
wollen sie mal waren gas geben
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wieder mal ein bekehrt so ist das und
mit diesen hoffnungsvollen worten gebe
ich zurück ins studio ging es ruhig noch
mal gas
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist niemand der stelle
[Musik]